[Musique]
tiens tiens bonjour ça quand on me voir
il fait un temps superbe aujourd'hui
dans l'île aux enfants
je suis en pleine forme ça nous donne
l'idée de faire un jeu vous êtes
d'accord
oui alors venez avec moi les enfants aux
enfants venez avec moi sur le banc on va
faire un jeu tout le monde s'installe
c'est c'est une petite à ce moment une
petite place les galas ou de même aller
vite vite vite vite
voilà on dirait que vous allez faire
injure et oui casimir
on va jouer au jeu air ternaire karachi
c'est mon jeu préféré
tu le connais ouais alors dû jouer avec
nous entendu à campbon alors je vais
vous expliquer le jeu air terre mer
je vais dire à toi ou à toi air terre ou
mer et à chaque fois vous me donnerez le
nom d'un animal qui vit sur la terre 6
gdi terre dans les airs si j'ai des airs
et dans la mer si je dis la mer 1
pourquoi vous voyez bien alors continuez
et vous chez vous vous essaierez de
répondre avant casimir quand
j'interrogerai d'accord alors on
commence et hirondelles terre à terre
disait t'es bon cécile mer
casimir mais ouais et alors ah oui alors
alors il faut répondre
amer d'une donne de l'eau d'un animal
qui vit dans la mer mer mer aller vite
vite vers un point sans volant avec des
packs un poisson volant est de dépasser
vos seins mais il se moque de nous là
non mais nous ne va pas 0 bon mais qaïda
mais mais gilmer une baleine terre terre
s'il est bel est un dromadaire c'est
drôle d'art eux mais aucun requin hier
françois tuées et cachées des réseaux de
la lève toi tu es lièvre mais est il
honnête casimir nerfs à quoi donc aller
re r aero change r à savoir c'est facile
souffle mois soufflé mois dites moi
quelque chose ni popotin volant à niveau
kazimierz a fait deux erreurs deux
erreurs la troisième s'est terminée en
renoncer ici lyderic et une grue père
mourant à l'écureuil mère grand mère une
tortue de mer de ces bons c'est gros
c'est ça qui est ça
cécile oui il m'a tendu un petit piège
dames et c'était bonnes réponses
cécile aird un petit oiseau un petit
moineau
voilà la vienne témoigner nos
alors michaela m papillon elle est
encore allée un rouge-gorge diedrick
mais un crabe
ah c'est vrai mais plus ça marche qu'est
ce que lui a pas répondu encore à quai
c'est bien moi j'ai répondu juste
toujours répondu air bon air terre mer
air terre
arranz elle pardon razel vous c'est
parce qu'au sein du christ c'est un
hareng gazelles mais qui a englouti
gazelle
las les trois erreurs casimir c'est
terminé mais j'arrête ça ne nous on
continue avec les autres enfants
tu es avec nous avec nous il alors terre
plr gris votre mère un dauphin françois
rrr encore encore et moi nous obligeant
kebbi michael à terre
z c'est encore taire bon casimir as tu
parles minea les émirats lors la
dernière question aller vite vite vite
c'est ta chance
russie 1 essayer de répondre cette terre
mais une fois deux fois trois fois
terminée avant hier un ver de terre est
là pour une fois il est donnée large ans
il veut bravo vue termine sur une botte
d'une termine sur une bonne réponse
alors voir casimir et à la prochaine
fois au revoir
[Musique]